[Music]
get those taals of wagon an all new AFV
animal Edition starts right
now most days it is great to be a lion
no natural Predators you can sleep all
you want food is literally
everywhere yes most days are
great except International Hug
Day because even on International Hug
Day no one really wants to get hugged by
a
lion it's okay she still has her
Pride welcome to America's Funniest Home
Videos animal
Edition and now when he isn't hanging
with the big dogs he's playing with the
puppies Alonso
rero hello everyone and welcome to AF
animal Edition the show that celebrates
the good times and humor provided to us
by our friends in the animal kingdom and
we have it all we're sort of like Noah's
arkc if Noah and his family had a bunch
of video cameras and
smartphones po goes the
toaster hey were you supposed to just
play marker on the box yeah okay but you
colored Henry Henry looks like a subway
car her Lee said she can only have one
dog so she hid one of
them
s hi
baby left paw right
paw
FaZe good
girl I don't think he's going to make
it yeah
no everyone knew that Tima did not like
to be bothered while watching his
favorite
[Music]
programs oh Tima I'm
flattered it isn't the knife that's
making him nervous it's this guy no oh
no oh no oh no oh no oh no maybe he's
nervous the Bug's going for the knife oh
no
[Music]
all the thrill of hanging your head out
the car window without ever having to
leave the house
[Music]
he's life is
good what's the magic word say please
come on Sully Sully do you want to go
outside say please say please manners
are everything okay come on let's go
outside Josh loved his
dog and he loved his
daughter and he was raising them
both the exact same
way that's good parenting right
there oh my
gosh I'm not going to lie I have the
greatest job in the world it's like a
dream come true but I have other dreams
as well someday I'd like to open a
little bed and breakfast in a small
coastal town I'd call it alonso's
Hideaway it'll be quaint and cozy a
place to get away from it all and relax
oh yeah and it will only be available to
mice tired of being a member of the Rat
Race and the daily toll it takes just
being a rodent in this day and age well
why not leave your overcrowded infested
digs for a well-earned vacation
at alonso's Hideaway
[Music]
that's right a cozy comfortable Paradise
with no traps no cats and no
exterminators stay in one of our homey
cottages and sleep the restful Slumber
that comes from being able to let your
guard down you'll Gorge to your heart's
content at the Alfonso hideaways all you
can eat buffet so make your reservation
now before we fill up for the summer you
may never want to
leave alonso's Hideway where it's good
to be the mouse in the
house the best advice in life is to be
yourself embrace it don't try and be
something you aren't just to fit in it
isn't always easy even animals sometimes
go through an identity
crisis yeah he thinks he's a
kangaroo Go Get It Go Get It yes I
literally have a cat that plays fetch
Sophie overheard them talking about
getting a dog so she stepped up her game
she'll go get it and jump up here on the
couch and give it to me and then I'll
take it and then she'll go get it again
and she'll do this over and over and
over Sophie feels it's a small price to
pay to keep a dog out of the house she
like the best freaking cutest cat ever
for
what I'm sure a lot of dogs love the
walk but Izzy was really starting to
believe she was a
dolphin holy cow the squirrels make it
look so easy so he decided to give it a
try himself he is channeling his inner
squirrel and he's pretty good A little
more practice and he might even attempt
scampering you know if the fence can
handle
it just because it's called a cat tower
does not mean dogs can't enjoy it as
well it's a perfect fit sort
of she's home she's home she's home
she's
home
yay who says dogs are the only ones that
get excited when you get home from
school now let her know how happy you
are good
[Applause]
dog now we all like to think our pets
are some of the smartest animals on the
planet and they are mostly but some pets
deserve extra recognition and find
themselves on the AF animal Edition
honor
rooll for the record the cat who
accidentally locked himself in the
closet did not make the honor
rooll it's the cat that leted him out
that made the Honor
role remember the Smart Ones need to
take care of the
others that is impressive good
[Music]
job this guy's a good whistler yeah you
do
it properly and make it honor roll
worthy come on you can do it
good boy good
boy of course not every pet makes it on
the honor
roll but it gives them something to
strive for oh my
God you might hear the rustling of leads
a chirp or a growl maybe even a park
ranger screaming dude drop the picnic
basket and run all things that let you
know you are about to have a close
encounter of the animal
[Music]
C if you ever find yourself in this
situation remember you're supposed to
say well played well played
indeed here he
comes after that encounter I bet Karen
isn't complaining about her view being
limited by the size of the space Between
the Bars now it was all she talked about
when they first got in the
water that's why they call them wet
suits nothing can keep Dylan from his
morning coffee so my kitchen is growling
at me this morning well almost nothing
as you can see I've got a beautiful M
line looking through my kitchen
window and I just need to get to that
kettle
to make some coffee that's
all oh
my the decision is should I go cold
turkey this morning have no
coffee what do you guys think Skip the
coffee skip the coffee what a
dilemma I don't know if this uh chicken
mesh is much of a protection let's not
find out we just need coffee
bit okay if that encounter didn't get
your heart pumping I am not sure what
the coffee is going to do for
you I love animals and I love sports so
you know I totally love it when a sports
team chooses an animal to be their name
and mascot and the more unique the
better which is why there is a new minor
league baseball team in Madison Alabama
that is on my list of favorites their
mascot is a raccoon but do you know the
super cool name of the team are they the
a redstone radical monkeys B Rocket City
trash pandas C Bama dumpster Bandits or
d yellow Hammer treasure cats well I
will tell you the answer when AFV animal
Edition
[Music]
returns baseball in mad Alabama just
outside of Huntsville definitely has a
face to put with the
tea the fans and players of the Rocket
City trash pandas the AA affiliate of
the Los Angeles Angels love to Rally
around their incredibly Savvy raccoon
mascot and his name is
sprocket and sprocket is
awesome we all know raccoons are
notorious for getting into trash cans
but sprocket prefers hanging out at the
Ballpark instead of the dunk sprockett
is often seen wearing his trademark
trash can rocket ship he made it himself
in a nod to the stadium being a mere 6
miles from the US Space and Rocket
Center and get ready for this space camp
it's why they call Huntsville Rocket
City so the next time you find yourself
in the great state of Alabama you might
want to take a little trip up to Madison
and say hello to sprocket
he's always ready to induct another
baseball fan into the ever growing trash
Panda
Nation go sprocket and go trash
pandas all right keep track of all your
favorite videos tonight because at the
end of the show we are going to award
$11,000 to the video we enjoyed the most
so see if our favorite video is the same
as yours all right want to see the
greatest card trick of all time I just
need total
quiet total quiet seriously this is
remarkable David Blaine said to me how
did you do that now think of a card in
any suit and I am going
to I guess I'll have to do it later
because it looks like it's time for
another episode of what's that dog
barking at
now oh the robots are coming and Reggie
for one is not at all happy about
it there is something so rewarding about
watching a large group all doing the
same thing at the same time it's what
everyone loves doing the wave
whoa
who so in that Spirit we'll be counting
down our top 10 pretty awesome stampedes
let's kick it off with the bottom
five number 10 Grandpa always always
under promised and overd delivered and
today was no different he told the
grandkids they would see at least one or
two
dolphins yeah this is overd delivering
on a major
level number
nine the baby elephant Stampede is sort
of off the charts on the cuteness
scale only thing cuter would be if one
of them was struggling to catch up oh
there he is
a number eight the
[Music]
chicken I totally get the expression
flew the CP
now number seven it has been over 80
years since they were replaced on the
nickel and they still aren't happy about
it
number six baby goat
Stampede wait for
Diego now quick baby goat Stampede the
other
way man I could do this all day
long oh what the heck one more time go
Stampy we will continue our countdown a
little later in the show
we all know that in life there are
things you do and things you don't do
the key is knowing what goes in which
category so to help you out it's time
for an AF animal Edition
don't don't touch a horse without
permission just
don't and don't wear that swimsuit and
hat combo ever that's a double
D A wise man man once said life moves
pretty fast if you don't stop and look
around once in a while you couldn't miss
it what Ferris bu was a wise man well he
was a wise teenager but he's a wise man
now that movie did come out a long time
ago but life does move pretty fast in
fact in the animal world if you blink
you just might miss
it when spear fishing it is important to
not appear like you are a fish
yourself can't blame the shark those
flippers do look
tasty will the shark go for the other
flipper or the Barefoot probably best
not to stick around and find
out a true sand artist can really make
the image come
alive isn't that amazing so lifelike so
real that trash can has a monster in it
she knew that much and kicking it didn't
seem to reveal anything so let's see if
Dad can Rouse the trash can
monster well he almost made it has
anyone seen my chicken
nugget I thought I left it on the
stove the problem with a series of blind
turns is you never know what's around
each and every corner
W you know had he actually hit the Moose
I bet the Moose wouldn't even
[Music]
feel and now it's time for the animal
News Network journalism that is
independent honest and housebroken I'm
Alonso barrel and here now the Animal
news it is deer season in Pennsylvania
and drivers are urged to use caution
when driving around the state and if you
find yourself driving near Cher's place
you should also be on the lookout for
the city's new implemented deer crossing
guard program yes helpful volunteers
have accepted the call to make sure
neighborhood deer get to where they're
going it answers the age-old question
why did the deer cross the road because
they knew they could do it safely thanks
to the deer crossing
guards police are warning drivers and
pedestrians alike that the dreaded
Rancho turkeys gang are back at it for
years citizens of the Rancho have had to
put up with the constant harassment of
the street gang known as the Rancho
turkeys and yes they are actual turkeys
mean those Rancho turkeys Rancho turkeys
members brazenly stop driving cars and
try and intimidate the passengers to pay
a toll of corn seed or anything they
might have in the car that a turkey
might like to eat apparently the Rancho
turkeys take to the street shortly after
Thanksgiving in an act of Revenge you'll
get your revenge on the 4th Thursday of
November we have an AFV aea Ann APB that
is an America's Funniest Home Videos
animal Edition animal News Network
animal points bulletin wow acronyms
really do save time authorities are
seeking any information in the
apprehension of this
guy as can be clearly seen in this
surveillance footage an unidentified
impudent squirrel shamelessly entered
the tantivy Mart headed to the nuts and
Candy section and after taking his sweet
time making a
[Music]
selection took a bag of candy and exited
the Mart without
paying anyone with any information
should contact the local police do not
approach the as salent he is a little
squirely has sharp teeth and considered
hungry after an unparalleled career in
the army Services rear Admiral chony
Horatio quacken ferter has retired known
as the toughest rear Admiral in history
and the only Goose to ever serve he
couldn't help but inspect the troops one
final
time even on his last day Quack and
furter towed the line he ran a tight
ship said petty officer boots McCaffrey
you stepped out of line and he let you
know it that's for sure later in the day
quacken ferter was awarded the
Congressional Medal of Pate the highest
decoration ever given a
goose and now it's time for an animal
News Network fake fact if you feed a
madagascan spider nothing but sugar
cubes they will spin webs made entirely
of cotton
candy not true I'm Alonso robero wishing
you the happiest of animal news and now
quite possibly the cutest thing you will
see
[Music]
today the best day of py the Penguin's
life was when they opened the butterfly
Sanctuary right next to the penguin
exhibit it guaranteed a good time would
be had by
all well at the very least a good time
would be had by
people see you later alligator after a
while crocodile but in that particular
exchange would you be able to tell which
one is the alligator and which one is
the crocodile well you definitely will
after
this alligators and crocodiles have been
kicking around the planet in one form or
another for approximately the last 70
million
[Music]
years they are as close as we get to
having living
dinosaurs but how can you tell them
apart we all know that one says see you
later and the other says after a while
but there's more to it than that for
starters alligator's mouths are Broad
and shaped like a u as in you better
stay
away while crocodile snouts form a
v-shape as in you very much better stay
away alligators tend to have darker
scales black or gray while crocodiles
are usually Olive or
tan but ask any small
fish and they'll tell you they all look
the same on the
inside let's talk
teeth crocodiles have mouths full of
sharp teeth that are visible at all
times but alligators have an
overbite so you won't see all their
teeth until it's too late
oh you can find crocodiles all over the
world most notably in Africa Asia
Australia and the Americans alligators
on the other hand are mostly native to
the southeastern United States parts of
South America and
China and there's only one place to find
crocodiles and alligators together in
the
wild South
Florida wow the Sunshine State really is
a cultural Melting Pot lastly you can
tell a crocodile by its beautiful
singing
[Music]
voice
okay not really I sort of made that one
up but now the next time someone says
see you later alligator or after a while
crocodile you will 100% be able to know
who is who and now you
[Music]
know oh hey check it out my neighbor's
dalmati is turning three and having a
birthday party next weekend Seems Like
Only Yesterday spotty was a puppy I love
going to animal birthday parties they're
so easy to shop for you just swing by
the deli and say surprise
[Music]
me it's time to play it's only 24 hours
in the day so we turn up and we turn out
and we ain't going to stop kicking us
out put the speakers ony in the street
the in the club make the party
people de
now in the SP it's time to come on
break tight everybody it come
[Music]
push
I love how some animals just perfectly
blend into their environment Nature has
given them the perfect camouflage take a
look at
this can you spot the
animal it's right there as plain as day
look carefully and I'll show it to you
when AFV animal Edition
returns
[Applause]
do you see the animal blending into its
environment okay how about
now there it is pretty as a picture and
right in front of your
[Music]
eyes some people get inspiration from
historical figures athletes Titans of
industry and even entertainers but for
me the best inspiration comes from our
friends in the animal world get ready to
be
inspired patience and perseverance will
pay off keep your eye on your goal and
stay calm you'll get there of course it
won't always be easy but you'll learn
from every
misstep can someone get Marco the
wonderdog a
tow While most of the Colony does the
heavy lifting there's always some
midlevel executive telling the ones
actually working how to do their job
better the Journey of a th000 miles
starts with a single step or a single
scooch in this case and the faster you
go the faster you'll get there ever
wonder if in countries that use the
metric system they are called 2.54 CM
worms instead of inchw worms I mean it
makes sense
right sure he could just leap up onto
the counter but wouldn't it be easier if
he just you know climbed
[Music]
Margie To the victor goes the
spoils hey
cool our countdown of the top 10 pretty
awesome stampedes continues we'll pick
it up with number five
and they thought it would be faster if
they timed the trip so they would be
going against
traffic number
four yes they usually fly south for the
winter but a lot of ducks like to work
on their cardio so they'd rather walk
helps them work off all that soggy bread
we feed them at the
park number three I'm pretty sure
getting caught in a daily golden
retriever Stampede is probably what
heaven is
like at least I hope so that's why I
always try to be really good I don't
want to miss out on
this number two when it comes to an
elephant Stampede it is always better to
be next to it as opposed to being in
front of
it no matter how slow they may be
going there certainly are a lot of them
Let's uh speed this up a
bit there we go and wait for the
Telltale sound that it's
over there it is we will reveal our
number one pretty awesome Stampede a
little later in the
show one of my favorite things to do
sometimes is to eat dessert first
seriously why save it for last between
you and me delayed gratification is not
all it's cracked up to be so go ahead
treat
yourself take it she said it was
okay
totally worth it I'll just be enjoying
this upstairs while I heal say
[Music]
cheese it'd be
humiliating if it weren't so
tasty give me P when there is more than
one dog in the house you have to be
quick give me P seriously you snooze you
lose give me Po
broccoli he doesn't want any stinking
[Music]
broccoli it's like they can hear the
crinkle of a potato chip bag being open
from miles
away it's like their siren song Calling
to them so they don't mind helping
themselves to a
treat
and he's out of
there when your dog doesn't like someone
trust your dog just
saying now it's time to see what we have
for you from our AFV animal Edition
[Music]
archive it isn't just the dogs of
billionaires that get to experience the
weightlessness of Zero Gravity by
launching into space nope Ranger gets to
experience it in this teeny tiny
plane I am so glad they have the windows
closed it isn't easy being the only dog
in a house full of cats especially at
snack time they tend to gang up on her
so it's wise to choose your
moment grab your
yummy and then back away
slowly never turn your back back on a
room full of
cats very deep loud they are if only
there was a way to quiet them
down
quiet
impressive one of my favorite animals
has got to be the Platypus they are just
so unique they have a bill like a duck
but they aren't a bird they are mammals
but they still lay eggs they don't have
a stomach seriously they don't their
esophagus connect directly to their
intestine female platypuses don't have
nipples but they still nurse their young
and just when you thought it couldn't
get any weirder male platypuses have
something else is it a a row of serrated
teeth b a small venomous spur on each
ankle C A forked tongue or D A disarming
smile think you know well I'll tell you
when AFV animal Edition
[Music]
returns
fun fact male platypuses have a venomous
spur on the inside of each ankle
connected to a Venom gland located in
their thigh the Venom is strong enough
to kill small animals and cause humans
some serious pain just one more unique
attribute that makes the Platypus one of
the most intriguing animals on the
planet all right let's take a look and
see what we have in the old AF animal
Edition inbox I hope that Nigerian
prince that wants to give me 20 million
writes back I gave him all the personal
information he requested ah all right
well here's our first email hey Alfonso
are there any animals that have a
reputation for being timid and demure
but deep down they are forced to be
reckoned with Ashley Watertown South
Dakota you know it Ashley take the deer
for instance they have the reputation
for being skittish shy and reserved but
when they need to they are more than
capable of stepping up some even have a
sense for adventure like fed stunt deer
Bucky MC
Buttercup that's Bucky right there and
he is known as the most adventurous
Daredevil deer in all of Michigan it
Thrills the tourists when Bucky bolts to
the top of the falls doing and then
Falls oh my
God Bucky does like to put on a show but
is Bucky okay did he succumb to the
terminal velocity of the teamon falls
will he ever resurface bucky bucky are
you
okay and he is
okay seriously if Bucky didn't make it
would I really be showing this to you
come on you know me better than
men our next one starts dear Alfonso my
wife and I are going away for the
weekend and she wants to hire a cows
sitter to babysit H the cows I say
that's ridiculous what say you Lenny
pcel
Oklahoma oh Lenny listen to your wife
the cows may seem capable of Behaving
while you're gone but you know the
expression when the cats away the mice
will play well the same goes for
cows cows are notorious party givers
before you and your wife are even out of
earshot they will invite their friends
over take over the yard and stuff is
bound to get
broken cow's really cut loose when no
one's
looking let's do one more Valerie from
akan Ohio writes de Alonso I am trying
to throw less items away and repurpose
them instead any ideas that's great
Valerie we can all do our part you can
use an old Tire to make a fun backyard
swing you can use old marbles to plug
knot holes in a fence and if you have
one of those play kitchens you could
always do this Gracie used to love
cooking toy chicken in her toy kitchen
so let's see what you doing here Gracie
I'm taking of the oh yeah let's see she
went from baking to caretaker what did
you do did you make them a nest she used
to let them nest in a bed of garlic
mashed potatoes but this is so much
better wow so they all have their own
little boxes huh and now she utilizes
every compartment
[Music]
oh you had them hiding in
there hm got any in the microwave and I
do mean every
compartment that is pretty funny that's
pretty funny let's see the other side so
think twice before having that old play
kitchen hauled off to the dump you can
always turn it into a deluxe chicken
apartment
building you cracked me up you cracked
me up too
Gracie keep those emails headed our way
and I will answer as many as I can and
to that Nigerian prince where's my money
bro the five animals of Chinese martial
arts are the tiger crane dragon leopard
and snake and of course I have trained
in the puppy style of kung fu where I
make my adorable puppy face and lull my
opponent into submission by sheer
cuteness sure Ronnie was a yellow belt
but Kitty was
self-trained the Mantis really only had
one move but you had to
admit it was as impressive as it was
confusing he'd only been taking karate
for 3 weeks but the whole family was
impressed with his
dedication well tell everyone except the
horse the horse didn't
care paw
block paw block P block P block and
treat something my Judo instructor gave
this is a fitness strap all right it's a
big gigantic rubber band and Max wants
to be in the Judo
video max that's cool let's try it again
take two
okay let's go this is going to be the
greatest Judo training video ever and
there's Max again that's
not Max yeah you're going to need to try
this some other
time here at AFV animal Edition we are
just one big happy family and just like
your family our pets are an important
part of it and since you are kind enough
to share videos of your pets with us we
wanted to do the same with our AFV
animal Edition staff members pet of the
day meet our producer Chloe and her
rescue tortoise
Morris hi everybody I'm Chloe and that's
Morris Morris's favorite things to do
are eat crunchy lettuce take long naps
out in the
sunshine and give me grumpy looks say hi
to Alonso
Morris oh Morris where you going you got
to say hi to
Alonso Do you have a favorite clip yet
don't forget at the end of the show we
will choose one video to receive $1,000
maybe we'll pick the same one we will
also share our viral clip of the week
and conclude our top 10 list all this
and oh so much more when AF animal
Edition
[Music]
[Applause]
continues clear your mind
AFB animal Edition is
back did you know that every second 74.2
million videos are sent by text or by
email of course you didn't because I
just made that up so let's just say a
lot of videos are sent every second a
lot and of all the videos the really
special and unique ones become our viral
clip of the
week at the University of Miami
Appalachian State football game the most
most intense action was happening not on
the field but in the
stamps all eyes were on the kitty in
danger and the crowd went
wild by the way Miami beat Appalachian
State
2523 and the cat was
fine if I can get serious for just a
moment I have been asked if I wouldn't
mind taking this time to explain you
know the the birds and the bees so so
here goes you see when a when a mommy
and a daddy love each other very much
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa not those birds
and bees actual birds and bees it's an
animal show oh oh oh oh birds and bees
of course of course animal show yeah no
no no no I get it I get it birds and
bees actual
ones check these
out a bee couldn't possibly open that
soda two bees on the other
hand do you have a kiss from Mommy kiss
some bird kisses are nice and
gentle others not so
much now Buzzy would be the first one to
admit he had put on a little weight over
the winter but he figured with all that
flying and pollinating the ounces would
just melt
away poor Buzzy this is going to take
longer than he
thought this duck just came up to me
I don't know what he's trying to tell me
but he's trying to tell me something do
you think it might be the khakis like
maybe he thinks you'd look better in I
don't know uh denim even corduroy
perhaps a dress slack hey buddy I need
those pants but do you all right I'm
getting out of here he really thinks you
need a new
[Music]
look the bees have moved in but that
lawn needs a moment it is the
suburbanites
conundrum oh yeah that mowa engine isn't
going to disturb them at
all well at least he will have a nicely
mowed lawn to look
at as he applies a bunch of calamine
lotion do you want more that bag looks
twice as big as him and twice as heavy
too oh wow that's what you get when you
don't take the dessert plates in at the
barbecue but some people really enjoy
the company of
bees like the beom for instance Mr the
bee woman and you thought the cat lady
was crazy turn around look at the
Bees honey there's a bee at the door I'm
going to let Jay get
it thanks
Jay we have been counting down our top
10 pretty awesome stampedes but before
we reveal number one let's take another
look at the first nine number 10 the
dynamic dolphin Dash number nine The
Baby Elephant
Walk number eight the panicky
poultry number seven the bombastic bison
number six baby goat gall
number five The Woolly Bully number four
the webbed footed
Walkers number three the retriever
Revolution number two the padder
pagination and now on our countdown of
top 10 pretty awesome stampedes we
proudly present number
[Music]
one isn't it always the way you announce
your city is hosting a 3-day banana
festival and instead of a stream of
flush upper class tourists word gets
around and every monkey from miles
around comes stampeding into
town the tourists are never going to
come
now that is number
one what a wonderful menagerie of videos
we have seen I told you it was going to
be like Noah's Arc on video did you pick
your favorite it was a hard choice but
the one we enjoyed the most and the
recipient of the $1,000 is buzzy B's
recent weight gain submitted by Tiffany
Skidmore of Elco
Nevada thanks Tiffany and maybe you can
use some of the money to get Buzzy a
salad this has been an amazing ride we
saw some incredible animals some tender
moments some animal bonding had lots of
laughs and if I'm not mistaken I'd go so
far as to say we learned a little
something as well we learned that even
when you know it's coming Gast can still
startle you we learn that shark cages
are a good
thing we learn that soda is always a
treat broccoli is never a treat and who
doesn't love
cheese we learn that Baseball fans love
sprocket the trash
panda dogs are scared robots will
replace them
too and next time this cat shouldn't get
seats up so
[Applause]
high
but most of all we learn that life is
too short not to spend it celebrating
the people and animals in our life and
laughing while we do it let's do this
again real soon good night
[Music]
everybody